the best trilogies are works of art that
tell one epic story in three chapters
for instance there have been three star
wars trilogies so far but only one of
them can be considered among the
greatest trilogies of all time which one
keep watching to find out
the log line for 1981's the evil dead
might seem like well trod ground for 80
slashers ashley ash williams and his
friends head to a cabin in the woods
only to cause a demonic uprising after
finding the necronomicon but in spite of
surface appearances the films in this
trilogy aren't paint by number slasher
flicks ash is far more of a fighter than
anyone michael myers or jason voorhees
ever hunted with bruce campbell's
hilarious high-energy performance making
him one of the best horror protagonists
of all time evil dead 2 continues the
story by essentially retelling it only
with more of the horror comedy thrills
fans had already come to expect but
director sam raimi veered into a new
direction for the third installment army
of darkness where ash finds himself in a
medieval fantasy searching for the
necronomicon to get back home it's a
jarring third act but campbell's
dependably badass performance is more
than enough of a reason to give it a
watch campbell and raimi are a tour de
force throughout all three campy gory
entrance into the greatest cult classic
trilogy in horror history clatto
okay then
that's it
no series about talking apes has any
right to be as thought provoking as the
latest planet of the apes trilogy it
began with 2011's rise of the planet of
the apes in which a proposed alzheimer's
cure grants captive monkeys human level
intelligence which they naturally use to
escape and form their own stone age
society the series continues with dawn
of the planet of the apes which sees
humans and apes fight over a ruined san
francisco after the avian flu wipes out
most of humanity and concludes with war
for the planet of the apes here the war
spreads and caesar the ape leader tries
to avenge his family after they are
assassinated by a rogue human
supremacist during a raid on paper this
all sounds preposterous but when you're
watching it play out on screen it's the
exact opposite powerful live action and
motion capture performances from james
franco gary oldman woody harrelson and
of course andy serkis in the role of
caesar bring these characters to life it
says quite a lot that a story about
talking monkeys could teach us more
about humanity than the vast majority of
movies starring actual humans
at the time marvel was casting for the
avengers chris evans wasn't necessarily
an obvious choice for the role of steve
rogers aka captain america his best
roles prior to captain america were as
bad guys like in scott pilgrim versus
the world or meat heads like in not
another teen movie he wasn't a total
stranger to playing superheroes but few
would consider his turn as the human
torch in fox's fantastic four movies as
a point in his favor but he did play a
world-saving soldier in sunshine and
that must have impressed someone at
marvel because when marvel's captain
america films first came out evans was
steve rogers his performance is the best
part of the first avenger showcasing the
characters world war ii arrow origins
this is followed by the winter soldier
in which his old pal bucky returns as a
brainwashed hydra assassin and civil war
in which international collateral damage
control turns friendships into rivalries
both of which represent blockbuster
cinema at its finest it's not easy
playing characters who could come across
as
too perfect the writers keep things
fresh not by giving rogers flaws to
overcome but by putting obstacles in the
character's path that challenge him and
us to rethink the nature of patriotism
and what it means to be a hero the
result is surprising captain america
makes it cool to be truly wholesomely
good
how to train your dragon follows hiccup
a gangly unthreatening teenager who
wants to slay a dragon to police's
father chieftain of the mystical viking
village of burke however after actually
capturing the beast he befriends it and
the two help defeat an even greater
dragon threat in the sequel hiccup
toothless and their friends uncover
family truths and encounter new threats
finally in how to train your dragon the
hidden world toothless falls in love
while hiccup searches for a dragon
utopia and battles a vicious dragon
hunter this third film succeeds not just
as a second sequel but as a satisfying
conclusion to the story all three movies
have humor heart and visually dazzling
animation for miles and makes how to
train your dragon the best animated film
trilogy ever made
the three flavors cornetto trilogy isn't
named after characters or overarching
plots because there are none sean of the
dead is about two immature best buddies
who have to lead their friends to safety
when a zombie virus breaks out in london
hot fuzz follows a no-nonsense london
cop who uncovers a criminal conspiracy
in a small english town with the help of
a bumbling local constable in the
world's end old friends reunite for an
epic pub crawl only to find themselves
in the middle of an alien invasion so
what do you call a spiritual but not
literal trilogy like this well as a joke
the creators made sure to include a
specific brand of ice cream cones in
each film and just named the whole thing
after those but a dessert brand isn't
the only thing these movies have in
common there's also brilliantly
inventive direction from edgar wright
charming performances from twin leads
simon pegg and nick frost as well as
huge laughs peerless writing and
heartfelt themes that are consistently
explored with disarming power they might
be narratively disconnected but each of
these films ranks among the most
lovingly crafted comedies ever made and
that's more than enough by the power of
grayskull
many time travel movies have been made
and some are great but in a lot of ways
they're all playing catch up with the
mighty back to the future the original
1985 movie features michael j fox as
marty mcfly who goes back to 1955 in doc
brown's time traveling delorean and ends
up having to play matchmaker between his
teenage father and mother the film's
sequel sees marty and doc traveling to
the future only to inadvertently bring
back elements of it to the past creating
an alternate timeline where high school
bully biff tannen becomes a powerful
millionaire in the third film marty goes
back to the old west to save doc before
he's killed by biff's great grandfather
the sequels don't quite match the magic
of the first back to the future but they
are worthy successors that hold up in
their own right thankfully hollywood
bigwigs have been merciful enough to not
resurrect this series with a fourth
installment you don't need one these
stand on their own
like the three flavors cornetto trilogy
there's no central plot that links the
three films in the man with no name
trilogy also known as the dollars
trilogy these spaghetti westerns helmed
by italian director sergio leone are
instead named after the man with no name
played by clint eastwood in all his
squinty-eyed no-nonsense glory each film
features this nameless poncho-wearing
anti-hero of few words practicing
vigilante justice throughout the
sandblasted old west of the 19th century
when the only law enforcement around was
whoever had the quickest draw get three
coffins ready in 1964's a fistful of
dollars the man with no name enters a
town split by corruption and greed and
plays the two rival families in charge
against each other in 1965's for a few
dollars more the man teams up with a
bounty hunter to track down a mexican
outlaw and in
1966's the good the bad and the ugly the
man teams up with a rival in a race with
a vicious criminal to find buried
treasure in a remote cemetery all three
rank among the finest westerns ever
produced with the good the bad and the
ugly considered one of the greatest
films ever made period
maybe westerns themselves declined in
popularity after this because these
three simply couldn't be topped
in the lead-up to spider-man homecoming
fans who'd already fallen in love with
tom holland's peter parker from his
cameo appearance in captain america
civil war expected something special and
they weren't disappointed far from home
was a worthy successor and a gift to
anyone still mourning the franchise's
spiritual finale in avengers end game by
the time no way home was released the
disney marvel team had turned exceeding
expectations into an art form at first
glance the trilogy refuses to retread
the same origin story we've seen so many
times already but this is a ruse no
spoilers but the ending of no way home
positions the entire home saga as one
gigantic origin story opening the door
to new spider-man films after six mcu
appearances the character has far from
overstayed his welcome
the three movies in the dark knight
trilogy might be stylistically
inconsistent but that's a future not a
bug it means each film is a standalone
work of art with a distinct visual style
that matches appropriately dark themes
of fear chaos and pain batman begins as
rough around the edges to reflect the
origins of the character bruce wayne is
inventing batman as he goes along making
mistakes suffering and learning what
works the two sequels are more polished
because by then both christian bale's
batman and director christopher nolan
are more confident in their vision the
dark knight is the trilogy's crown jewel
as one of the greatest superhero movies
ever made he's ledger's joker arguably
outshines the rest of the cast but he's
far from the only thing here that works
and while the dark knight rises doesn't
quite live up to the standard set by his
predecessor it has more than enough
energy heart and bombast to work never
before have movies treated the batman
mythos not just with respect but as
literary texts in their own right by
taking the materials seriously and
covering everything with grit and
shadows rather than campy mind numbing
action these movies turn a story we're
all familiar with into something fresh
engaging and truly unforgettable
there's something magical about star
wars sure there are movies from the same
period that have aged better and many of
the sequels have disappointed fans but
ever-growing legions keep coming back
for more devouring books comics tv shows
action figures and video games
converting new generations and making
regular pilgrimages to an original
trilogy that they hold in reverence the
power of a new hope is its simplicity
it's the same knight saves the princess
story we've seen since the dawn of
literature just with lightsabers and
starships instead of swords and steeds
but the characters are timeless and the
world building grabs the hearts and
imaginations of fans in a way few
fictional settings are capable of doing
the empire strikes back does just what a
sequel should building on what works in
the first while challenging audiences
with a darker tone and one of the
greatest twists of all time the return
of the jedi is more uneven but still a
mighty conclusion to the story
regardless the world's insatiable desire
for star wars proves that george lucas's
story is far greater than the sum of its
parts it's a force of nature a
fundamental property of the universe
with no end
in the fellowship of the ring nine
companions set off to destroy sauron by
casting his one ring into the fires of
mount doom where it was forged in the
two towers and the return of the king
frodo sam and gollum continue their
journey to mordor while the rest of the
fellowship rallied the free peoples of
middle-earth for the epic battle to come
you could make the argument that it's
cheating to include movies based on
someone else's story especially if the
first two parts are clearly the
beginning and middle chapters of a
larger tale and not complete stories on
their own our counter-argument would be
this the well-documented difficulties of
adapting j.r.r tolkien's epic massive
and
labyrinthine lord of the rings books for
the screen more than offset the
convenience of having the story plotted
out beforehand and even if that wasn't
the case peter jackson's impeccably cast
brilliantly acted series is too much of
a masterpiece to ignore it's filled with
some of the greatest battle scenes ever
filmed breathtaking cinematography and
set to one of hollywood's greatest
musical scores by howard shore each
movie tops the last and holds up
incredibly well but why are you taking
our word for it you're overdue for a
re-watch check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite movies are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]